the carriages are sitting empty they
used to be sold out now the few tourists
here just walked past but the horses
still have to be fed and cared for the
futurists who still come here won't be
using our services the Russians used to
book us for group sleigh rides if they
won't be coming there won't be any
carriage drivers anymore did the gurukul
take the gres out of it zakopane is a
leading resort in poland's tatra
mountains the town is not only popular
with polished tourists until recently
many visitors came from Ukraine and
Russia but the Ukraine crisis has led to
a sharp drop in visitors from Poland's
eastern neighbors democracy after sets
but between the third and the tenth of
January alone people from the east made
up eighty to ninety percent of all the
tourists in zakopane and it was that
group that booked up to ninety percent
of our rooms not sure capella travelers
who still come to zakopane despite the
crisis often can't afford to buy very
much the strength of the polar zloty
means that everything is much more
expensive for Russian and Ukrainian
tourists whose currencies have plunged
in value three on top to the hotel and
restaurant owners and retailers are
especially feeling the decline in the
number of tourists because Russians and
Ukrainians used to spend a lot of money
here revenues are sinking opinions
usually zakopane attracts some two
million visitors a year with its ski
slopes mountains and fresh air tourism
is the primary source of income for the
city's 27 thousand residents even sales
of the local cheese specialty Oh sh t
peck have plunged
this dudes are bushy it's much worse
than last year but we'll survive so
zecco Pawnee has decided to attract
visitors from Western Europe but it's ad
campaign has not yet born in a fruit and
now it's the season when Orthodox
Russians used to celebrate Christmas in
zeco Pawnee but few are showing up
Eastern customers also have different
expectations compared to Westerners you
Jolteon customers from Eastern Europe
are very demanding they want a drink and
eat a lot they want to have lots of fun
and they don't pay any attention to how
much it costs sup watches it western
europeans tend to be more reserved and
less generous people in zakopane are
hoping that at least they have lots of
snow this year a long ski season could
certainly help make up for the lost
revenue